the Sun is going on lockdown yeah this
is the most important story we do have
one where we talking about UFOs or
whatever but this lockdown is really
interesting because it kind of goes into
you know the global warming coronavirus
has reached the Sun it's the Sun oh this
the Sun is going into a Democrats have
have told the Sun to stay at home yep
don't go out into lockdown we got to
keep in lockdown Sun Wow what they can't
have the sunlight disinfecting the
coronavirus that's okay we're joking
don't ban us YouTube's working security
theorists let's uh let's read it that
was definitely a joke YouTube but is it
this is interesting
salt it's called something a solar
minimum we did we did briefly mention it
before in a past episode but we're gonna
do it yeah jump into the story let's see
what's going on let's do this the Daily
Mail reports now the Sun has gone into
lockdown reduced activity on solar
surface has sparked fears of a doomsday
mini ice age so is it time we saw the
light asks Jane fryer big news this week
about the giant burning boiling spinning
thermonuclear reactor which lies 93
million miles away from Earth what is
our primary source of life-giving heat
and light that was the stupidest way to
say we have news about the song what on
earth was that I don't want to be mean
but come on that writing is terrible
alright I'm gonna just skip over this
weird waste of time yeah that's really
what it is let's go down it turns out
the Sun has gone into lockdown recession
or more accurately a deep period of
solar minimum minimum which means that
the activity on the sun's surface has
fallen dramatically and its magnetic
field has become weaker letting into the
environment more of the sort of cosmic
rays that cause dramatic lightning
storms and interfere with astronauts and
space hardware they can also lead to the
explosion of sprites clusters of orange
and red lights that shoot out of the top
of thunderstorms like 60 mile high palm
trees in the sky that is awesome it's so
cool oh yes and on top of Olivet
theoretically it could cause the
temperature on earth to drop to
potentially catastrophic new lows while
the Met Office and members of the Royal
Astronomical Society are urging us not
to panic and reminding us this is just
nature nothing to worry about
and the sort of thing that happens every
11 years or so as the Sun passes through
its activity cycle some doom and gloom
errs are much less optimistic i'ma just
interject a bit and um nature is scary
and nature is often reason to panic what
if a volcano explodes and you're nearby
well you don't want to panic but you
should be alert and worried and running
yeah I think it's funny that's like it's
just nature calm down yeah someone
mentioned tennessee is a potential spot
all I can think is don't they have
tornadoes every year that ripped through
Tennessee in the center well you know we
can't run from the Sun so if the Sun
yeah stops that's a good point yeah it's
just I wouldn't panic you know what I
just kick back put my feet up and be
like well are we gonna do I know you you
drive that van down by the river we
don't know if the world was anything and
the Sun was going out I just sit back
and back me I'll probably go skate the
ramp work yeah like well we'll skate
into infinity I just probably would do
nothing different I'd be like well here
we go what if like what would you do if
say like Australia right now got hit by
like a massive you know just like
asteroid or meteor whatever does and
then we were told on why Australia
because we're far away from it okay good
and then you got tourism like on the
news they were like the impact wave will
reach you know the East Coast the United
States in one hour and so we're sitting
here like you can see the glow in the
sky and we're like in one hour this
devastating wave will just white we'll
just like we're dead yeah you have one
hour
Wow that'd be crazy no be nuts what you
do I'd probably find nish yep
spend that hour with her find your loved
ones yeah the way I always see it is
like when you're dead you're not gonna
care right so all right but let's read
check out this photograph I love this
what an extreme solar minimum is thought
to have contributed to the so called
Little Ice Age in Europe in the 17th and
18th centuries when the temperatures
fell so low the River Thames froze over
yet why snowed in July it's this picture
that is not what happened in the 17th
century for those that are just
listening it is like Big Ben covered in
ice frozen up to the clock and there's
like some kind of tanker like boat ship
just yeah somehow up like halfway
through like the distance of Big Ben to
water level rose I guess and so
there it's yeah but that has never
happened alright but we're checking out
this I'm cool stuff
she writes perhaps they're haunted by
the extreme solar minimum thought to
have contributed to the so called Little
Ice Age in Europe in the 17th and 18th
centuries when the temperature fell so
low the River Thames froze over crops
failed lightning storms lit the skies
and in 1816 the weather was so crazy
that it snowed in July as we all know
the Sun which is 4.5 billion years old
and more than a million times bigger
than the earth is not only a source of
cheer when it finally pops out from
behind the clouds it also keeps us alive
which means that the tinniest change in
its activity levels can have
extraordinary consequences triggering
lightning storms the appearance or
disappearance of the Northern Lights and
those amazing sprites but the sun's
activity is changing constantly as it
passes through its regular cycle from
solar maximum hottest and most active to
solar minimum quiet and cooler since the
17th century scientists have been
measuring the depth of a solar minimum
by Counting the sunspots areas of
magnetic activity on this solar surface
which show up as relatively dark spots
and solar flares large explosions that
hurl charged particles into space the
general rule is the fewer the sunspots
the more severe the minimum and the high
the chances and the higher the chances
of lightning storms sprites a disruption
of earth so far this year the Sun has
been blank with no sunspots 76% of the
time a figure passed just once since the
50s last year when it was 77 percent
blind so could we be heading for a grand
solar minimum based a sustained period
decades even centuries or particularly
weak solar cycle are we now on top of
everything else facing another mini ice
age so what do you think huh interesting
so so we could actually be are all this
climate change the client that we've is
lives we have we've been messing it up
preparing for the temperature to be
lower but we've been raising it so it's
actually just gonna be normal
it's gonna be normal for you it was
coming they planned it they were like
man look all this global warming I know
we need to do we need to burn off a
bunch of co2 warm up the planet that way
we don't have a mini ice age yeah there
you go
it reminds me of Futurama why is it
always this show I don't
no because it's a genius show because
it's sci-fi true and because we talk a
lot about you know kind of sci-fi stuff
yeah
but they to combat global warming they
just went to a comet and took a big
piece of ice and dropped it on into the
earth okay to like because it cooled it
down nice and then they need a bigger
and bigger ice block every single time
they do it and so the final solution is
all the robots aim their exhaust their
butts to the sky and then again exhaust
and it pushes the earth a few meters
away creating an extra week or something
but also cooling the earth down the
problem yeah so what's gonna happen
right they say two hundred years ago we
were deep in the midst of the Dalton
minimum which occurred between 1790 and
1830 and was marked by periods of brutal
cold temperatures fell by two degree 2
degrees Celsius over 20 years which may
not sound much but had the effect of
devastating the world's food production
and causing widespread famine so we're
about to add this on top of this and
Emmett that's interesting though because
aren't we at the point of about one to
two degrees higher than average I have
no idea so what I just said as a joke
could potentially actually be the truth
but we didn't do it on purpose
no I know that I was basically we did it
on accident alert not an accent we were
like are in the industrial revolution it
just kind of happened you know what we
developed what you're saying is that
humans collectively slipped on a banana
peel pulled off a perfect backflip and
land it on like a throne like oh I
really do that yeah but what happens
every 10 years yeah it's well then it's
gonna spike back up to get really really
hot temperatures yeah yeah unless unless
the solar activity well we're not at
maximum so in 40 years of so they also
had they said the misery was exacerbated
by powerful volcanic eruptions Wow
the second largest volcanic eruption in
2000 years happened on Mount Tambora in
Indonesia killing more than 71,000
people and plunging the temperature
still lower a giant as the s giant ash
clouds blocked the song yeah it was a
hot mess
Wow how come nothing fun like that
happens really sound fun Jim don't you
jinx us man what
fun is the wrong word thank you I'm
gonna see all the outrage like people
died to these future what I mean is time
not fun but like consequential mmm like
a pandemic right okay yeah kind of but
this is not even nearly as bad as emic
is like a just a it's just another I
don't want to call it the flu but it's
like a new thing that is just basically
like a flu going through is worse like I
know I know it is weird were some sure
image but that still is what's happening
though I'm just saying like the Spanish
flu killed millions right cope it's
probably not gonna get that bad and no I
don't think so you know we're taking
care of it but it's really just people's
hanging around what you know hanging it
hanging out their homes a lot of people
have lost their jobs they're getting
really really angry about it yeah so the
economic crisis is actually much worse
or I should I should say as the
potential to be substantially worse yeah
than then Cove it is but I just mean
like alien invasion great war massive
volcanic eruptions spewing ash into the
sky for hundreds of miles or thousands
of miles like that would mess us up yeah
like nothing seems to happen it's like
we're in this boring period it's a
golden age it really is dude you guys
are gonna wake up tomorrow Yellowstone's
gonna be blowing up and we're gonna be
like oh there will be no sunlight no
more snow more Sun so we're gonna do it
all of America we're gonna dig straight
down in the basement and we're gonna
grow mushrooms in the dark and mole
people
yep all people mushrooms in the door we
could just keep digging and see if the
lizard people will take us in that'd be
good we get deep enough we'll go to
Colorado where's that that was that yeah
yeah so someone said we can't wait to
see what's after the murder Hornets yeah
you know what go man
like they they always tell us these
crazy things are happening and they're
always just it's not that bad no it's
not like we remember growing up when I
was little and they were like you know
killer bees were coming yeah I never saw
anything I never actually I did see
killer bees once but bees are that that
it was kind of scary look really yeah
what was it it was like a dark cloud of
bees oh yeah they're just regular bees
but I saw him in in the sky and they
were kind of like passing me but I heard
them and it was right around that time
they were like watch out for killer bees
and I was like oh wow oh that's well you
know I was in
where was I st. Louis maybe I don't
remember
it's just just your regular old wasps
and hornets yeah everybody thinks
Yellowjackets are bees too
I'm offended by that those things you
liked it when I lived in LA like the
bees you could walk past any bush and
there's just swarms of bees yeah you
walk right past it
I don't bother you at all they don't
care Yellowjackets oh they're like whoa
you offend me
no no attitude there they're like I'm
looking for something to eat
ooh here's a person I will chase after
them sting him you want to you're crazy
story man yes when absolutely when I was
in grade school we were in church okay
and I was sitting in a Pew and in front
of me there was this girl mm-hmm and she
had like her hair in a bun or whatever
and I watched a yellowjacket land on her
her bun oh man
but I wasn't really paying attention so
it landed and then like we were singing
or something yeah and then it crawled
into her shirt huh and I noticed and I
was like hey hey like there's a there's
a B and then what by the time she
noticed the the wasp freaked out yeah it
was Thunder 16 times lost did you start
going
yeah they don't die it was like the
worst yeah I saw it
there's this guy on on YouTube I don't
know his name but he does this with all
these different venomous things he like
brings him to his arm and let some sting
of yeah I did that with the murder
Hornet and he was he was laying on the
ground rolling around it is and then it
likes it buffed up to like this huge
mound I was like whoa it's crazy-looking
how did he rate it on the scale like he
said it was worse than anything else
no way he kept saying this this one I
don't remember what it was but it was
the previous like yeah worst thing yeah
and so much worse there's like an ant's
like a big and or something right it
like just bites and red ants right
answer no no there's like a big ant it
like jumps what I don't know about this
yeah you know what I'll tell you what
man I bet right now as we talk about
murder Hornets people in Australia are
laughing yeah crack it open I crack it
open of fosters and no a murder Hornets
meanwhile like a giant like 35 spider is
like yeah like spitting acid and like
you know they're like an umbrella with
the acid falling on them they're like oh
it's a normal day in Australia yep
black widows everywhere brown recluses
and they're just like me yeah yeah
mm-hmm yeah Australia's crazy what's up
with that I don't know I've never been
there I really want to go I've been in
New Zealand New Zealand is like so that
so Australia and New Zealand have
endemic species okay but New Zealand's
endemic species as far as I can tell
they're like what the Kiwi dude I think
I mutilated my cats when they brought
when all the little bird yeah they're
like they're like the ball-shaped birds
with like long lace
oh yeah right right because they didn't
have any cats at a time and so yeah they
survived two Europeans came in and
analyse the house cats there's a dude in
New Zealand who called for all house
cats to be killed oh my goodness and it
was like a huge controversy and he was
like but they're just killing everything
every bird I do
yeah yeah and so it was like a big deal
I guess in New Zealand but it's funny
that you go to New Zealand it's like
very peaceful and very chill and the
Kiwi vert like the Kiwis very silly and
just like a you know it's a civil this
this news is coming out that they're
getting all authoritarian now well yeah
because I crazy because it's not a lot
of people live there uncle I don't I
think the total population of New
Zealand is only like four million or
maybe 8 million or something hmm
yeah so like everybody knows everybody
it's like you know I guess it's it you
know not literally but much more than
here but you compare New Zealand's
animals to Australia's animals and it's
like Australia is like Australia's like
a final were five times the size though
or maybe even more I don't even know
that's a that actually is the u.s. yes
huge but it's most like desert in the
Midlands yeah yeah but you got crazy
critters on that place man giant weird
creatures it's it's it's it's it's uh
they're one of the final levels you know
what living out in the bush easy it's
it's it's hard mode hey I'm good I
watched Crocodile Dundee take a really
big knife I really love that movie
though actually I love that did neck
isn't that guy who did that movie like
the only thing he's ever done I think so
yeah well he did the second one and the
third one yeah and that's not a knife I
never saw the third one cast we do the
show live Monday through Friday at 8:00
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune into
this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you